ragazzi oggi siamo su geox che non
faceva da un sacco di tempo lo faccio
sempre con un ospite e today
abbiamo il buon jean che che mi dava una
mano perché di jean è laureato in
geografia scandito si darà una mano oggi
naturale ecco io di geografia ma
sicuramente
ragazzi oggi giochiamo vultur eder vabbè
allora giochi essere un gioco che ti per
chi non lo conoscesse c'è questa mappa e
lui ti mette lo sai come giocatore ti
mette in un punto a caso del mondo così
che questo che sta vedendo in grande e
devi capire dove sei
puoi muoverti devo ricordarmi tipo
vedere i cartelli sono cartelli italiani
questo è un cartello globale quindi tu
devi capire dove sei nel mondo cercare
più o meno di capire muovendo tiro per
leggere una presona roba randomica per
capire un attimo secondo me non siamo in
italia non si possono mai visto così
tanta nebbia
siamo a silent hill allora sino ai
cartelli non sono italiani fino qua mi
ha veramente buttato in un mondo c'è
quasi serbo per il classico gesto cioè
ti puoi scegliere le zone in genere giu
l'italia e invece questo come il
classico giocherà dove ti mette
veramente in un punto a casa dal mondo
dagli alberi e da un la targa la targa
la targa è censurata dai brevi però
dalla pancia del tizio sicuramente
fossimo in america molto a signor rossi
a sé o in russia siamo nell'est europa è
il tipo di discorso di prima
prima che ha fatto un'ora di discorso
che le russe o sono in uk issime o sono
quelle veramente che tipo sollevano in
tronchi esatta lannocca e quelle che
sulle varietà allora abbiamo capito che
siamo in in est europa era del russia e
capo il gomitolo detto che andava e no
perché cirignano potrebbe essere russia
polonia
la troika ha certo lista con
l'ombrellone
lui ha vinto si è fan c'è una nebbia che
tra un po arrivate riley e silent hill
ma lui è uscito boa che bella giornata
per andare poi tesoro io vado fare di
pesca io voglio sapere la vita le
fortune e i miracoli di quell'uomo vive
in questo qui è vivere in una scatola
verde bellissimo andiamo denner dai
partner
beh dovevamo eravamo della russia
completamente dall'altra parte per
l'attenzione che però è la linea e
linear c'eravamo ancre di bile si era la
mia seconda scelta naturale aimo
facebook a wow non sapeva che questo
pezzettino fosse russi nemmeno io io
pensavo fosse sempre qui la russia
confina con la corea del nord
ma dai non lo sapevo non lascia la cina
uno sputo di mare non è vero non c'è
niente la cina non amare perché la
stessa del prodotto
no c'è la parte sua però quella parte no
jaguar e la parte russa ma perché sono
cattivi quindi sono veramente vicini
alla russia e giappone si vabbè comunque
sul clima c'è un extra ue canada punto
virgola per adele bellissimo che ci
mette sempre in mezzo al niente non
capiamo nulla dai questo è bellissimo
gesto come carla america mi sa da dagli
alberi che vedo credo america più
america perché casa sono club sia nel
senso america come continente si varano
le cassette per forza siamo meglio le
case signora di dove lei che sarà
location di the walking dead
te lo dico io eccolo di avere 20 lì
svezia degli ardenti europa dell'est o
svezia norvegia finlandia europa del
nord dai azzecchiamo almeno in
continente
almeno il continente dice svezia la
finlandia maya la morte pro die die però
ci siamo avvicinati alla mamma mia e
dove cosa falsa mento bambini ma dove
vabbè vabbè lasciamo che cosa sta
contattando gli alieni come l'antenna è
così che mettono sul naso i padri paglia
sì sì sì è una perché sento più buffa
oggi se sabrina gli spikes il primo
albania sparando potrebbe non so se
questa è albanese però potrebbe essere
proviamo quando mica mente guarda io mi
fido di te i maniaci la geografia e la
mi fido di man e anch'io albania senti
punto dimezzata sa che doveva albania
viene di alcoli tirare si grande
l'albania grandissimo casa che era rio
de janeiro schifo
la prima intuizione america del sud
c'era l'ultimo 5 su 5 solo per vedere
cosa andiamo a finire queste è
assolutamente adesso può fare bellissimo
se vai avanti non c'è niente per ora
stata dritta questa terra rossa proprio
o può esserci linea grangia bo
clementina qualche nuova incredibile
civiltà da qualche parte vi prego non è
un paese fantasma
ma in quel paese di residenti paul 4
esatto ad atene e moschee
mi scusi dov'è è proprietà della signora
teresina 3 signa si poteva essere
brasile proprietà tesi e brasile brasile
brasili direi di metterle brasil tipo
quella mazzoniano apparati pò qua da
paravia premi paravia dall'altro la lama
era brasile sempre lì è porco skip pro
die onesta già sono cavata signora
visualizzare pio che abbiamo fatto un po
schifo tranne la finlandia
sarà stata molto questa per scaldarci
ragazzi allora posti famosi sicuro ha la
mia vecchia scuola piena di gente morta
con like e teste di bambini che rotolano
giù per le scale è sempre america del
sud
non vorrei dire cazzate ma mai al non
sta secret credo sia tipo machu pichu
non è il machu pichu questo no questo
noi non ci piace sicuro al mille per
mille
però e questo è sempre una costruzione
di origine america primordiale torna che
figo come sulle magliette ma è già
scritto hard rock maya arrivare l'uomo
che fa la volta google che ha fatto la
foto è la cellula farò cerca di
tutelarci per il fatto che facciamo
schifo in geografia tutelavano sta
ignorando n sapere che negli anni
novanta ci fu una crisi economica del
sistema scolastico quindi hanno dovuto
togliere alcune lezioni tra cui gioca
tra cui geografia per cui quando io e
lorenzo andavamo a scuola anche se
lorenzo è un pelo più piccolo di me in
quel negli anni 90 inizia nel 2000 la
geografia non veniva insegnata quindi
quel poco che sappiamo e siamo andati
noi per nostras ponte per la nostra 7
culturale andare a lecce romania 7
culturale dico che sta roba si trova poi
livia diego torna sulle magliette perché
magari c'è scritto ai presenti quello lì
che ne so quando tu vai bologna sicché
tipo vai che ne so se sia alla torre di
pisa e cioè tipo la maglia e tradita
pisa magari qua a bologna siamo qua a
bologna però magari sulle magliette dei
rivenditori ambulanti trovi la scritta
di dove a questo posto bambino piange
perché gli hanno rubato i giocattoli
cile di 0 c a c era guatemala va a
cagare dirla nello yucatan di un meno no
non è vero abbiamo preso niente di punti
ma bene next meno male qualcosa mi
conosco finalmente siamo su google siamo
c'è una macchina di google ha fatto una
foto è vero che la maglietta di google
esatto guarda incredibile ragazzi allora
aspetta rimani fermo su questa immagine
su di lui photoshoppate melo
sull'immagine di adamo detto credito dio
è perfetto vi prego attaccateci lo
vogliono la riposto la riportiamo lui
sta dicendo google io sono google
fuori fuori 16 alla reggia di versailles
immagino di sì eravamo quasi mai igad my
friends proprio loro grazie mamma sarà
turnover se questo col khalifa esatto la
rabbia dobbiamo andare in arabia saudita
mamma mia ragazzi cosa sta facendo e sta
partita incredibile
la vacca di 3 kg tanto alcol labour
khalifa che sfiga vabbè ci siamo dati
preda in che la mia ragazza
mamma mia se tu dici parto addio
immaginati la macchina di google qui
stato parcheggiato che non sta capendo
quando lui non ha capito niente esposti
questo era il mio posto ci credo siamo
in grecia ci siamo siamo portava a casa
siamo in grecia
dovremmo essere appunto al al tempio di
atena sull'acropoli suo esatto
no ragazzi non incredibile incredibile
ma è vero maestro
mamma mia ma cos'è il talento cattolica
finalmente napoli era ora
e roberto tratta questo che la donna del
gabibbo lofar bubbles viaggiato su
aragon e la gondola di buchi di google
questo è certo
tra l'altro dove però c'è nel senso dove
venezia e direi giriamo finché non trova
un centro di lovere esatto aspetta
quella la riuscita eravamo qua quindi
spot on
incredibile a 5 metri 5 metri proprio
esattamente sopra mondo l'ha sempre
tutti tranne guarda sono quello ci
assomiglia a quello cioè quello perché
era incredibile cavolo
però siamo andati molto bene tra
lattiero dino momento bene giro sono
veramente straniero ragazzi grazie per
aver visto il video siamo veramente
giuro soddisfattissimi se volete
invenzioni di geografia della tennista
nell'istruzione ci sta pagando
no non è vero che poi ci pensa veramente
non è vero stiamo scherzando era per ri
ri integrare un pò di geografia perché
noi l'abbiamo vissuta male quindi
vogliamo fare per avere la meglio di
quanto abbiamo visto però vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi con l'assenza salito al
momento mi piace anche ministro c'è come
giustizia dove siete noi ci vediamo come
tempo da ragazzi
[Musica]